[Applaudissements]
bonjour je parle
c'est c'est la langue que je connais le
mieux puisque je suis auteur de romans
jeunesse écrit en français
alors je veux présenter la business je
suis universitaire professeur de
linguistique mais là ça vous intéresse
pas ça n'intéresse que mes étudiants les
pauvres pour vous je vais pas vous
parler de deux de mes passions qui sont
l'écriture des romans jeunesse et qui
sont l'ornithologie ornithologie c'est
la science l'étude des oiseaux c'est le
fait d'observer les oiseaux de les
regarder dans le ciel et là on est au
mois de mars
c'est la pleine période de la migration
des oiseaux
ça va continuer pendant plusieurs
semaines et c'est quelque chose que
normalement je ne rate jamais l'année
dernière j'ai été obligé de la rater
puisque on était confiné j'espère que
cette année on aura l'occasion de voir
les oiseaux faire leur migration
alors je vais vous parler du premier
point qui est auteur de livres jeunesse
alors j'écris depuis on va dire une
trentaine d'années des livres destinés à
un public jeune
soit deux des enfants de 8 10 ans soit
et ça c'est plutôt mon public des jeunes
de 12 à 15 des récits d'aventuré qui se
passe exclusivement en tunisie la
tunisie c'est mon pays et c'est des
aventures qui se passe dans différentes
régions de la tunisie
ça peut être le nord les forêts du nord
avec une aventure comme ceux louvier la
panthère ou l'extrême sud avec une
aventure comme le fils du désert
là j'ai emporté avec moi mon livre
fétiche c'est les mystères du belvédère
un livre qui on est maintenant à sa
troisième édition c'est à dire qu'il ya
une première édition qui a été épuisé
une deuxième édition
et là on en est à un troisième essai
ou richement illustré grâce à
l'illustrateur donc chercher l'âme
c'est une histoire qui se passe dans la
médina de tunis moi je suis né à la
médina de tunis et je raconte mon
enfance dans cette médina
on était jeune j'habitais dans une
maison arabe vous avez des maisons
arabes c'est des maisons avec patio où
le seul si elle condamnait un carré
puisqu'on est dans un patio et on
regarde le ciel on a un carré bleu c'est
tout ce qu'on a de la nature où quelque
sorte est la seule escapade qu'on avait
quand on était petits c'était d'aller au
parc du belvédère
le parc du belvédère c'est le plus grand
parc de la ville de tunis
et alors là j'ai imaginé une grande
histoire qui se passe dans ce parc avec
des péripéties des coups de feu faisait
vraiment je ne vous raconterai pas
l'histoire mais c'est réellement une
histoire qui met en jeu deux jeunes des
jeunes garçons donc dans le narrateur
qui ont 12 13 ans et qui vont vivre des
aventures dans ce parc magique est en
fait le le le point de départ de cette
de ce compte de ce roman c'est les
tunnels du belvédère vous avez le
belvédère on on y a il y a deux très
longs tunnels qui ont été causés pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale
et quand on était petits on pouvait on
pouvait y accéder
et donc j'ai imaginé une histoire qui se
passe au fond du parc à l'intérieur de
cette une
voilà c'est l'une des aventures qui se
passe à tunis et j'ai d'autres aventures
qui se passe dans d'autres villes par
exemple le fantôme de sébastian aidant
par sébastien ses passions qui se passe
dans la belle ville de aba bête et plus
exactement dans un espace qui s'appelle
maintenant le centre culturel de la
ville de hammamet où il y a justement
dar sébastian de ses bastions c
le l'homme qui avait qui possédait ce
domaine qu'il a cédé à l'état tunisien
qui est devenue centre culturel
ça va je reprends voilà je continue ou
monsieur réalisateur s'il vous plaît
qu'est ce que je fais alors ça se passe
dans la belle villa de ses bastions qui
se trouve à à me mettre ses bastions et
l'homme très riche le poète le peintre
qui a imaginé ce centre est donc j'ai
imaginé une une histoire qu'ils
appellent le fantôme de ses bastions qui
se passe justement dans cet espace
magique et là aussi j'ai été accompagné
pour ce roman de la plume et du dessin
du même choqué la main donc est venu qui
a fait de belles illustrations pour
cette histoire qui se passe
hammamet il y à d'autres histoires qui
se passe dans d'autres endroits de la
tunisie dans une collection qui
s'appelle un kilomètre à pied une
collection donc j'appelle un kilomètre à
pied parce que il suffit de faire
quelques kilomètres à pied pour
découvrir un monde très très diversifié
moi ce que je raconte dans mes mes
livres pour enfants et pour adolescents
c'est un amour pour la nature et pour ma
chère tunisie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]